in this video i explain to you
everything about the t-test for
independent samples and how you can
easily calculate the t-test online with
data tab let's start from the scratch
there are three variants of the t-test
the t-test for one sample
the independent sample t-test and the
dependent sample t-test the simple
t-test is used to check whether there is
a difference between a group and a given
test value this t-test is very often
used in quality assurance for example to
check whether a produced screw really
has the given weight on average the
independent heat test is used to check
whether there is a difference between
two independent samples for example if
there is a difference between the salary
of man and women the thetis for
dependent samples is used to test
whether there is a difference between
two dependent samples for example
samples where a person was interviewed
at two different points in time
this video is about the t-test for
independent samples in the description
of this video you will find links to my
videos and tutorials about the other
t-tests
now you may ask yourself what is the
difference between an independent and a
dependent sample
independent samples are made up of
independent people and measurements
a person in a sample is not related to a
person in that sample there are two
completely independent groups
for dependent samples the measured
values are available in pairs the pairs
result for example from repeated
measurements with the same persons
so this person is exactly the same as
that person
they are simply questioned at two
different times for example before and
after a surgery
with the independent sample t-test we
consider just this case namely
independent samples
but what do i need the independent t
test for
let's say you want to check if there is
a difference between two groups in a
population for example if there is a
difference in salary between men and
women
of course it's not possible to ask all
men and women for example of a whole
country about their salary
so we take a sample this means we create
a survey and we send it out randomly to
people
in order to be able to make a statement
about population based on this sample
we need the independent t-test
therefore the research question that can
be answered with an independent t-test
is is there a statistically significant
difference between the mean values of
two groups
possible questions could be is there a
difference between people who have a
university degree and people who don't
in terms of their health or another
question do two production plants
produce screws with the same weight and
do smokers have a higher risk of heart
attack than non-smokers in order to
calculate an independent t-test the
hypotheses must first be derived from
the research question hypotheses are
assumptions about reality whose validity
is possible but not yet proven there are
always two hypotheses the so-called null
hypothesis and the alternative
hypothesis the null hypothesis assumes
that there is no difference between two
groups with respect to a certain
characteristic for example the salary of
men and women does not differ in germany
the alternative hypothesis however
assumes that there is a difference
between two groups for example the
salary of men and women thus differ in
germany
furthermore we distinguish whether a
hypothesis is directed or undirected
this plays a major role in the
interpretation of the results at the
very end but more about the
interpretation of the results later
first of all what is an undirected and
what is a directed hypothesis
undirected hypotheses test whether there
is a difference whereby it does not
matter in which direction the difference
goes for example there is a difference
between the salary of men and women
however it is not checked whether men or
women have a higher salary it's only
checked whether there is a difference or
not another example is the assumption
that there is a difference in heart
attack risk between smokers and
non-smokers and again in an undirected
hypothesis we do not test whether one of
the groups has a higher or lower risk
but only whether there is a difference
or not a directional hypothesis
additionally gives the direction of the
difference for example men earn more
than women in germany or smokers have a
higher risk of heart attack than
non-smokers in research directed
hypotheses occur most often because in
most cases you want to test the
direction but what about the assumptions
for the t-test
we'll look at them now
what are the assumptions for the
independent t-test there is an
independent variable for example gender
which has two characteristics or groups
for example male and female these two
groups should be compared in the
analysis the question now is is there a
difference between the two groups
regarding the dependent variable for
example income so now we have four main
assumptions and we'll take a closer look
at them first the two groups or samples
must be independent the variables must
be scaled in intervals the variables
must be normally distributed and that
the variance within the groups should be
the same let's start with the first one
the two groups or samples must be
independent as the name of this t-test
suggests the samples must be independent
this means that a value in one sample
must not influence a value in the other
sample this is the case when you measure
the weight once from a group that dieted
and ones from a group that did not diet
but you don't have an independent sample
if you measure the weight of the same
people once before and once after a diet
feel free to watch my video about
dependent and independent samples the
second assumption is the variables must
be scaled in intervals in order to carry
out the t-test for independent samples
the mean value of the sample must be
calculated this only makes sense if the
variable is interval scaled an example
would be the weight of a person in
kilogram but the educational level of a
person so secondary school high school
and so on is not interval scaled
the third assumption is the variables
must be normally distributed the t-test
for independent samples gives the most
accurate results when the data from each
group are normally distributed however
there are exceptions in special cases
for example the weight age or height of
a person could be normally distributed
but for example the resulting number
after throwing a dice
is not normally distributed let's look
at the next assumption the variance
within the groups should be the same
since the variance is needed for the
test statistics t
it is important that there is the same
variance within the groups this could be
the case for weight age or height of
people but for example the stock prices
in normal times and in a recession may
have a different variance so now the big
question remains how do i calculate a
t-test well there are two possibilities
either you use a statistic software like
datatab
or you calculate the t-test by hand we
will now go through both we start with
the calculation with data tab and then
we go into details of the individual
formula this will help you to understand
the t-test even better in order to do
this we simply go to datadeb.net
and copy our own data into this table
the data set is actually a bit small
with only 12 cases but as an example it
should be enough then we click on
hypothesis testing now you just need to
choose here below the variables you want
to evaluate
let's say you want to know if gender has
an influence on the salary so you just
choose salary and gender now data tab
automatically calculates a t-test for
independent samples
if the assumptions for the t-test are
not fulfilled
you can also simply calculate the man
with me you test furthermore you have
the possibility to calculate an
undirected also called two-sided
hypothesis test or a directed also
called one-sided hypothesis test
in a directed case you must then specify
what your null hypothesis is so the
question is do men or women have a
higher salary here below you can read
the respective hypotheses
the null hypothesis is the female group
has smaller than or equal values as the
male group
for the dependent variable salary and
the alternative hypothesis would be
the female group has larger values for
the dependent variable salary
than the male group
but let's start with the two-tailed case
first
here we see the descriptive statistics
and the box plot
after that you will get the levine test
for variance equality the levine test
for equality of variance tests whether
the variances of the groups differ
significantly from each other for
example
whether the homogeneity assumption of
the variance has been violated if the
p-value for the levine test is greater
than
0.05 the variances are not significantly
different from each other this results
in a p-value of
0.09 which is above the defined
significance level of 5
the levine test is therefore not
significant and the null hypothesis is
confirmed therefore there is equality of
variance in the samples since we assumed
equal variances we can now read the
p-value from this row we get a p-value
of 0.056
let's say we chose the significance
level to be
0.05 in that case the p-value is greater
than the predefined significance level
thus the null hypothesis is retained if
you don't know exactly how to interpret
the p-value
feel free to look at the summary in
words
a two-tailed t-test for independent
samples equal variances assumed showed
that the difference between female and
male with respect to the dependent
variable salary was not statistically
significant thus the null hypothesis is
retained
in addition you can also check the
assumptions here of course you should do
that at the beginning of your analysis
now i will show you which formulas are
behind the t-test for independent
samples depending on whether your group
has an equal or an unequal variance
there are different formulas to
calculate the t test to find out if
there is variance equality or not the
levine test for variance equality can be
used
this test checks whether several samples
have the same variance if the p-value in
the test is greater than 0.05
variance equality can be assumed let's
start with the formulas for equal
variance
in the case of the t-test we want to
calculate the test statistic t
this is obtained by calculating the mean
value of one group minus the mean value
of the other group of course this
difference plays a major role the
greater the difference the less likely
it is that both groups come from the
same population this result is then
divided by the standard deviation of the
mean also called the standard error the
more the mean varies the more likely it
is that there will be a large difference
in the mean between the two samples even
if they come from the same population in
the case of equal variance the standard
error is calculated using this formula
and 1 and n2 are respectively the sample
sizes of group 1 and 2.
sp is obtained by using this formula
here s1 is the standard deviation of the
first sample and s2 is the standard
deviation of the second sample if
everything is inserted the t value can
then be calculated using this formula
the degrees of freedom result with n1
plus n2 minus 2. now let's look at the
case with unequal variance and then go
through
what we do with the t value in the case
of the unequal variant the t value is
calculated with this formula now of
course the question is what to do with
the t value a statistic software simply
calculates the p value from t value and
the degrees of freedom but this is a
little bit difficult by hand
in this case you read the critical t
value from a table
and compare that critical value with the
calculated t value you can read the
critical t value from this table
the link to this table can be found in
the video description but how does that
work let's look at an example
let's say we have set the significance
level of 5 percent if we are testing an
undirected hypothesis this means we
split the five percent between the left
and the right so we have two point five
percent on the left and two point five
percent on the right therefore in the
table of critical t values we need to
look at 97.5
this is what we get by subtracting half
the significance level from one so we
are in this column now
let's say the degrees of freedom in our
case is 6 so we are in the table in this
row the critical t value then comes out
to be 2.447
now we need to check whether our
calculated t value is smaller or larger
than the critical t value if it is
smaller the null hypothesis is retained
otherwise the null hypothesis is
rejected if you have a directed
hypothesis you have five percent on one
side then you don't have to check the
table at
0.975 but at
0.95
and you can read your critical t value
here
of course you still have to check
whether the results go in the direction
of the alternative hypothesis i hope you
like this video and see you soon
you